see youtubers is Charlie so awesome news
the rock finally confirmed they're going
to do Black Adam to movies I'm going to
explain what's going on and why he is
going to help save the DC Universe along
with the flash he had this big meeting
at DC Comics that he was teasing the
producers that are on the project right
now just hyping things up saying how
they are going to bring fun to the DC
Universe now that's in addition to
what's going on with Justice League the
flash movie Aquaman so I'll explain all
that so there's this long history of
Shazam in the comics it's a little
confusing so I'll give a brief
introduction on the character too but
there's a new round of the flash ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video so we got to talk about how
the rock in the flash are going to save
the DC EU
I feel like Batman will too but he's
more of a known quantity I feel like
it's a lot easier for characters you're
not totally familiar with to surprise
you and that's really where the rock
comes in and everyone's just been saying
how awesome the flash is so we'll
explain all this number 5 what is going
on with the Shazam movie so originally
it was going to be a Shazam movie back
around 2014 the rock was brought on he
was like oh hell yeah you know I'm going
to bring it it's going to be awesome I'm
gonna kick so much ass so everything was
good but that was during the original DC
EU release schedule since then that
schedules changed quite a bit so what
they're doing now is they're going to do
two movies set in the same group of
characters and one of them will just be
a total black atom movie so the rock is
just getting his own spin-off movie in
the other movie will presumably just
focus more on the Billy Batson character
with black atom in it so number four why
are they doing this like why they
splitting it into two movies well this
is a really good idea I think just
because there are so many Shazam
characters they're all DC characters but
the Shazam family is so big and so
complicated in the backstory is so crazy
that I think they just need some more
time to flesh that out and you get more
movies you get more time to develop the
characters it winds up sidestepping that
problem where you try to stuff too many
characters into a movie so they haven't
officially announced the release
State but originally that Shazam movie
was set to come April 5th 2019
they might just fast-track the blackout
a movie because they haven't cast the
Billy Batson character yet but they do
have the rock in the DC Universe
definitely needs the rock right now way
more than the rock needs the DC Universe
this is where we get to the idea of the
rock saving the DCE you not
single-handedly because there's like a
couple really big things that are
happening in the next couple years that
I think will just completely turn people
around that aren't really big fans of
what's going on right now so like the
Wonder Woman movie Justice League are
all big steps in the right direction I
think they'll be great but someone like
the rock who just oozes charisma and as
a PR machine is just so good at getting
people into theaters think about what he
did for the Fast & Furious franchise
those were entertaining movies but when
he came on board with that fifth one
that's when it really started to go
crazy that is a multi-billion dollar
franchise and even though I think the DC
movies are way way better than the Fast
& Furious movies but the rock is just
one of those people who is just so great
at playing that alpha male character and
that is so much what Black Adam is so if
you're not familiar with his backstory
he was the original Shazam character who
turned evil then much much later the
wizard Shazam created a new one and that
became Billy Batson and he was the good
one they fought each other they became
mortal enemies but if you're a little
confused or you haven't read comics in a
while or you still think the characters
called Captain Marvel what happened is
is back in 2012 DC officially stopped
using the Captain Marvel name because
Billy Batson Captain Marvel was what the
character was originally called when he
started at Fawcett comics before DC
bought the brand so this is great story
about the history of that character
there's the Marvel family already it
sounds like a big legal nightmare so
number three what happened way back in
the early 1950s is is it DC pressured
Fawcett comics to stop using the Captain
Marvel character because he was a
up off of Superman way later DC bought
those characters and started using them
but in that time Marvel created their
own Captain Marvel character and
trademarked it so Marvel owned the
trademark even though Fawcett comics
created Captain Marvel before them
because of that weird distinction DC
continue to use the Captain Marvel name
all the way up until near 2012 when they
officially just started calling Billy
Batson Shazam
because most people behind the scene
just felt like you looked at him and you
thought that he was Shazam anyway but
technically it's the wizard Shazam in
the Marvel family so for all those that
are wondering that is why the character
is no longer called Captain Marvel is a
trademark issue DC just doesn't want to
get into some long legal battle with
Marvel Comics but number two you know
what they might do for the story of the
movie is adaptive version of the new 52
origin story which is a little bit
simpler and it explains how you get the
family but they might just cut out the
family they might just use the Billy
Batson character during that origin
story you learn how the Black Adam
character is very similar to Billy
Batson they both grew up in extreme
tragedy Black Adam escaped slavery Billy
Batson lost his parents he's been on his
own with these foster children for a
while you learned how black Adam wasn't
able to move past that childhood trauma
worry not black Adam cannot fit you here
my gravest mistake one for which today I
will pay my penance but linear ago I
chose him to be this world's protector
he was entrusted with great powers but
his heart was collected by that he felt
they're doing the same seven deadly
enemies a man that all I was forced to
banish him to the farthest star and God
assist the next 5,000 years making sure
I would not repeat that error I chose a
new hero why you of course I've been
watching you for some time Billy and now
bestowed with the wisdom strength
stamina power courage and speed the God
you become our new protector
you will become Captain Marvel so when
he became all-powerful he just became
this crazy dictator trying to save
people by sort of like crushing them
under the burden of his freedom so he
thinks of himself as a hero even though
he's so extreme that he is definitely
the antagonist Billy Batson on the other
hand learns to adjust learns to be a
hero in actually defeats black Adam by
tricking him not using force just
knowing that black Adam is such a badass
there's no way he could ever beat him in
a fight because black Adams about five
thousand years old he tricks him into
turning his powers off and he basically
turns to dust so that's his end in the
new 52 obviously the movies aren't going
to kill him off that way so fast but
it's a relatively linear story where you
learn about the seven deadly sins like
all the backstory behind the Marvel
family how their powers work so shows am
is actually an acronym for all the
different gods whose powers they get and
they basically can call upon one power
at a time
so there's stamina swiftness strength
wisdom power and courage that's black
out of power so they can call upon those
at any given time we just how they're
able to fight Superman but because their
powers come from magic Superman is very
weak against them so usually you defeat
Black Adam by tricking him somehow just
because if you were to try to go pound
for pound with him you know look at the
rock here he would beat you into a pile
of jell-o imagine The Rock punching
Henry Cavill as Superman with lightning
fist like it'd be so crazy which is why
you know number one I feel like Wonder
Woman and Superman would be great cameos
in these Shazam Black Adam movies just
because Wonder Woman comes from a very
mystical place
Superman is one of the few characters
that's as powerful and he's this big
influence on Billy Batson because you
have to remember that even though he
becomes this adult when he activates his
powers he's still like an 11 year old
kid so what a coincidence that the same
week the rock is meeting at DC to sort
of figure his movie out he's also
hanging out with Henry Cavill they also
share the same management
company so there's all this stuff is
just pointing towards collaboration
coming up so it's going to be a lot of
fun and when the rock posted this that's
basically what he was saying this is one
of the reasons why he's going to save
the DCE you because he can be hardcore
but a lot of fun at the same time so
that is where the flash also comes in
too so I feel like the aesthetic of the
DCU is totally on point they did an
amazing job with the look and feel but
some of the really fun characters just
aren't there yet like Wonder Woman was
barely in Batman V Superman we haven't
seen justice league yet so we haven't
really got a lot of the flash yet so
people like Aquaman too like all these
characters that are going to be so much
fun just haven't quite arrived yet which
is why we're all waiting for the Justice
League trailer so I know everybody's
still wondering when that's going to
come there's going to be some new Wonder
Woman really soon because that movie is
coming out in June they'll probably drop
some new Justice League relatively soon
but I'm not expecting a Super Bowl
trailer there might be some teaser
around the Super Bowl but I'd be very
very surprised so let me know what do
you want them to do with Black Adam in
the Justice League franchise but I feel
like they'll slowly have to introduce
him in one of the Justice League movies
they've already shot the first one so I
feel like the second movie is actually a
really good target for that and he's
just going to be such an awesome jolt of
energy into the DC EU in the same way
the flashes for Justice League I love
the way that all the Justice League
actors are saying their favorite
character is the flash in the Justice
League movie so I think everybody's
going to be really happy with the way it
all goes down let me know in the
comments though what kind of DC movie
videos you guys want me to do or even
for the TV step two there'll be a lot of
flash TV stuff happening because it's
coming back next week but later today
I've got some new Logan movie posting
I'll be talking about the x-23 character
the future of Wolverine inside the Fox
universe so it's going to be a lot of
fun while you guys wait for that to post
you can click here for a new flash
trailer for next week's episodes and you
can click here to rewatch the in just
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight